[Music]
hey everyone its Johanna here so ladies
unpaid fat we absolutely dread it and it
may cause us to be more self-conscious
in sleeveless tops now remember we
cannot spot reduce fat so in order to
get rid of on the fat or fat from any
parts of our body we have to reduce our
body fat overall through exercising and
also eating a well-balanced diet so a
full body workout consisting both cardio
and strength training can help to reduce
body fat and also to get rid of the
stubborn armpit fat today's workout will
aim to tone the a big fat area through
chest exercises which will also include
shoulders and arms muscles so grab me a
pair of moderate with dumbbells between
four to six kilos each and let's work
out together so you can do this workout
on a mat on a bench or other stress ball
which will make you more challenging
so grab your dumbbells and make sure
that they are in line with your chest
and we will start with chest press so
slow and steady four counts one two
three four up to three or good slow
touch the floor and bring it up slowly
nice and controlled
so really control your muscles and do
your chest and the armpit area working
she was slow and after this we will
speed it up one more slow nice and
control bring it up slowly and I'll give
me ten quicker reps one two good three
good control four five six so keep me
quickly but deep control to down seven
eight nine ten good now let's go five
more slow ah really smoking true your
muscles squeezing
- 3 loong nice and control squeeze so
all the way up really user chest muscles
its squeeze don't you show this without
your abs good one more up squeeze and
now just hold the other bottom and just
power 10 times 1 2 3 4 halfway through 5
6 7 8 past small pulses 910 good job
drop a little mouse next Rica we want to
be doing stagger push-ups push-ups is
one of the best upper-body workout to
really tone this entire area ok instead
of the normal push-ups for stagger
Cuccia you want to place one arm just by
a chest level and one arm about 3 inches
forward ok this will challenge your arm
even more and to really work on the
chest muscles so up onto the floor ok
one arm here and there and let's go give
me 6 on each side one good 2 up 3 4 5 6
now change side right forward and give
me six more 1 2 3 4 5
six very nice and no grab it on us again
because we have one last final exercise
which is flying you have to do fly and
fly really works on the ultimate chest
muscles and also the cleavage area to
really tone this entire area up
so grab your dumbbells bring it up okay
palms facing in and you just want to
open it slowly drop your elbows touch
the floor and squeeze it up so give me
five slow blacks and really control the
dumbbells
nice and easy good - nice and easy
three more really control it I want you
to incorporate every single chest
muscles shoulders and arms muscles of
yours good squeeze it squeeze it good
two more nice and control open it up
feel your chest use your chest one more
and then after this give me ten quick
arrest ready let's go down squeeze down
squeeze good down squeeze three and you
feel the alter public transport game I'm
preparing a gift for five squeeze six
seven eight last two nine ten good and
now give me five slow one again one slow
me control control good slow and steady
open it up touch up if you find this
difficult you can either reduce the
weight slightly or bend your elbows more
and it will
easier three control last two and before
we end we want to do small pulses one
more open it up squeeze and now let's
get down and just hold it here
and just give me ten slow - one - can
you speak to the other part of your
outfit I can feel it Unser's off five
six one seven eight nine seven bring it
in
well done bring the dumbbells down and
good job so take a one minute rest
between sets and repeat this circuit two
to three more times do this workout two
to three times weekly and combine it
with your total body cardio and
strength-training with consistency you
will be able to wear sleeveless tops in
no time and remember that it is natural
for us women to have a little bit of a
beef fat even if you are already slim
even I have unfit that if I wear the
wrong tops so choose tops that will
flatter your body and avoid toss which
are too tight around the outfit area all
of us for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my youtube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
[Music]
you